let me start by saying how much I loved
this movie although I'm sure you're
hearing that from literally every person
coming in the room movies incredible and
and also this is your first movie yeah I
give you a lot of credit I sincerely for
all three of you this is such an unusual
script in the way that it balances
comedy and everything about the script
is so unusual can you sort of talk about
reading it for the first time and what
you took away from the experience I mean
I loved it was the first script that I
read and I can't read I'd read one page
crap like the only thing I've ever read
seriously I read it know and it's the
only thing I've actually been in touch
and I like how it's it's it's a comedy
but it's also it's also really sad and
it's very well kind of the it's very
well balanced and such because he's
trying to tango showing him really kind
of dark and quite scary time and history
and a scary kind of what's the one scary
story but he bounced it with comedy so
he kind of feel more engaged with her
and he kind of could relate to it more
and and you could also kind of yeah you
could see the deeper meanings well yeah
is this teiescope she picked up and you
just immediately like this is gonna be
something really special and I'd be over
the moon and incredibly lucky to be a
part of it yeah let's just see this mr.
Cooper you I don't know it's like a book
you can't put down you just won him you
know it was a beautiful script I mean it
was act
you know people could actually had
access access to the script as a whole
because it was it was of course there's
a lot of improvised stuff in there you
know that made it on the screen but the
actual writing was it was just as
perfect little gem and you felt the
uniqueness of Tyga's voice when you read
the script in it it's funny because we
were saying some people before the film
obviously has come out have asked us to
give kind of a long line it's impossible
to pitch the story
it get you go down so many part of the
pun but like rabbit holes trying to to
pitch the story because the tone of it
is tyka and it just has its own its own
flavor but that when you read the script
you could you knew you felt that and you
knew exactly like how how it's going to
be people watching this if you want to
find it when it's gonna be in the award
conversation they're gonna put the
script out there for people to see
I'm sure it's um I have to ask you one
of the things is that you're you're
pretty young but I think it's very
important every year for like a World
War two movie to come out to remind
people of the atrocities and what really
happened can you sort of talk about that
thing because so many people still don't
think certain things happened it's like
their mind is so closed yeah that's true
it I think what's it's this film is
unique in the sense that it kind of
delivers that message through comedy and
so you know the audience is having the
shared jovial experience and they're
able to kind of laugh at all the
slapstick stuff and then when these
impactful moments happen and the facts
are right there in front of you which is
kind of like hits you so powerfully that
you're left with this kind of profound
feeling of you know of of loss and the
weight of the reality of this war and
the atrocities that happened you know to
to so many millions of people you know
and and I think what what remains in
this story which is so beautiful as this
hopeful message of love and connectivity
and this shared experience of you know
of two two young people you know really
able to find you know this is kind of
any sense of childhood and
even though whatever all this horror
that they've been through they still
they find each other with imaginary play
and and you know just the sameness of
being human
because then you when you think of your
charge it's like a special thought but
then for them must have been fine I'm
just like you say this it's doing that
we can never stop telling people always
need to be need to be reminded of it and
and we need a it's important to see and
different kind of from different points
of view and different perspectives and
then and throw different lenses and then
yes we needed to be reminded of it and
we need it's a warning not to let those
things those what's just hateful things
ever happen ever again completely
Stephen Merchant mentioned when I talked
to him with Sam Rockwell that he was
always trying to get Sam to break on
camera that was the admission to get in
the laughs did he try I mean he's only
in the movie a little bit but did he try
that with you at all or what was it like
on set with you yeah you didn't need to
yeah that character was terrible
I'm ready Ike you were ready to get what
seems Sam because we do these lines and
yeah no he never
who's Sam yeah he like and I'd be
laughing at his little tenure I'm gonna
switch and say a tiger is such a gifted
actor director writer what was it like
to collaborate with him on set and what
maybe surprised you about the experience
I think everybody knows that Ike is a
hilarious guy I'm an incredibly witty
and humorous and but I think also just
working with him I learned up what he's
got such a big heart
and he has really important stories to
tell and messages says she observed I
wasn't surprised by that but it was just
yet nice he's yeah just a kind guy yeah
he he also is such an amazing actor and
you see like he he hears the rhythm of
his diet of the dialogue and his
in his mind and he's so in tune to how
things like the musicality of dialogue
which is why I think the pacing of this
movie is so fantastic and all of his
films have like an incredible pacing to
them you know he finds it also like in
the Edit and the musical choices he
makes and how things are visually
jarring and how they juxtapose and he
just he has an amazing he's an
incredible visionary and his aesthetic
is so is so unique even the way he like
presents himself is is so particular and
I was I was always impressed by that how
he is like a comic genius that way he's
very good at composing life and energy
and such he's always you know it's much
like posture and kind of like kind of
trying to kind of like oh yeah my life
is kind of like that it's not kind of
it's kind of loud and it's sometimes the
conversations are fast fast paced and
personal yeah on that note I have to
stop I'm just gonna say again
congratulations of the movie it's one of
the best of the year and have a
fantastic day
thank you